Oh my God, Sam, what is wrong with you?
Normal things that everybody does.
Honestly, though, that made it affordable.
That made it so that I can afford to run this.
That's awesome.
Dude, the amount of time you spent rewriting that TLS library
cost you more than that freaking compute power ever would.
I don't know.
I was scanning the entire internet for like 20 bucks a month.
It was nothing.
Hey guys, check this out.
There's a bug bounty program right now that is paying 6.25 times
its normal bounty amounts.
It's brand new and the scope is so massive
that there's practically a 0% chance of dupes.
And it's a white box testing environment,
so you've got access to source code.
This is a bug hunter's dream come true
and it's the WordFence bug bounty program.
Get this, the scope for this program
is every single WordPress plugin above 50k installs.
So there's thousands of plugins already
and it's expanding every single day.
It's a crazy opportunity
and the team knows it's frankly a little crazy.
So they had to put a cap on the number of reports
a researcher can have active at a given time
and they capped it at five.
But for you, the critical thinking listener,
thanks to the sponsorship,
you guys get 20 active reports at a time
and you'll get an extra 10% bonus on top of your report
when you mention critical thinking
for your first submission to the WordFence bug bounty program.
So it's an amazing opportunity.
Head over to ctvv.show slash wf,
ctvv.show slash wf for WordFence
and get more information, submit some crazy bugs.
I know you guys are going to crush it.
All right, let's get to the episode.
All righty, we got a super special guest today,
Mr. Sam Erb.
Welcome to the podcast, man.
Hi, long time listener, first time caller.
Yay, dude.
That's great.
Well, thanks for coming on, man.
And I appreciate you listening.
I do know that you do listen
because you'll ping me from time to time
and talk about stuff from the pod.
So definitely, definitely appreciate that.
Yeah, yeah.
I, you know, this is on my rotation,
you know, and I'm like doing dishes or showering.
I don't know.
Listen to this.
Showering.
Yeah, the best time.
That's true.
You got to get those shower thoughts in, you know?
Oh, yeah, man.
Yeah.
It's actually been really cool too, you know,
that because we've, I think, I almost said Shopify.
Spotify has been coming out with those, you know,
like, what is it?
2000?
Yeah, the wrapped.
Wrapped, yeah, thing.
And people have been like, oh, you know,
we listen to critical thinking all the time,
you know, top whatever percent listeners.
So definitely, definitely appreciate that.
So I guess normally at the beginning of this podcast,
we will go into like little history of Sam,
you know, and that sort of thing.
But I think we're going to skip that this time
and we're going to come back to it later.
And we're just going to jump right into
some hacker methodology stuff, okay?
Because, so just for, okay,
I'll do a little context.
All right, just a little context.
Tell the people who we're talking to.
All right.
So this is Sam,
currently Google employee,
hacker extraordinaire,
one of my top respected hackers
and one of the most influential hackers
in my life as far as, you know,
methodology and like,
I guess, hacking techniques that I respect
as far as that goes.
So Sam, really happy to have you here.
And I kind of want to dive a little bit
into what makes you so special
as a bug bounty hunter and a hacker.
And my theory is that
that is largely coming from a background
that is not related to web security, right?
So talk to me a little bit,
because you were a low level,
I guess you were doing low level development, right?
In the beginning, or was it always security?
You know, I know you were working with stuff
that was not web related.
Yeah.
So it's always been web tangential,
I think is the best way to describe it.
Yeah.
And security tangential.
But I spent a decade as a developer.
Yeah.
So I worked at Cisco for a few years
doing crypto hardware integration.
Yeah.
So this is exactly the shit I'm talking about.
Like crypto hardware integration.
You know, like a question.
Okay.
So I guess I want to hear about that.
And we're going to hear about that.
But what I really want to get to
is why is this whole concept
of going wide and versus going deep?
And I categorize hackers by this, right?
And you hear me talk about this on the pod all the time.
You are very much a go deep sort of hacker by my estimation.
And so I'm wondering,
do you think that's a function of, you know,
having spent so much time at a lower level
that you're more comfortable at the lower level
so you try to get down lower and lower and lower and lower?
Or, you know, is that an intentional decision made by you?
That's a really good question.
I think there is a certain amount of,
like, I am comfortable going and reading an RFC
and then, you know, applying that somewhere
and trying everything that I can find in the RFC.
But at the same time, it's, you know,
having been a developer,
it's like you kind of, you know what mistakes,
like to me anyways,
it's, you know, what mistakes developers make
and then you can go and find those mistakes in the wild.
And, you know, the security engineering side of that,
it's like, how do you prevent those mistakes from happening
or build frameworks that don't allow them?
But yeah, I mean, you've seen it.
It's, you know, there's been a lot of instances
where, like, I think that there should be a bug there
and, you know, I will spend, you know,
10 hours going off and reading RFC,
which is just, like, you know, completely,
it's not the healthiest thing in the world,
but it's like once you get fixated on something
that might be vulnerable,
then, like, it's hard to think about other things.
Yeah, for sure.
Do you think that, like, also your engineering
sort of, like, background has pushed you
to be more of a, like, a technical hunter
rather than sort of, like, that black box hunting?
Like, I think a lot of the hacking that I've seen you do
sort of is diving into, like,
how does the source code for this work
or, like, reading through, like,
sort of the more open source sort of approach.
And do you feel like your engineering side
has really pushed you in that direction as well?
Yeah, absolutely.
Like, I want to understand how the systems work
to break them.
The story that I tell, actually, a lot is, like,
this was at, like, one of the U.S. government
live hacking events.
Somebody from the U.S. government was, like,
you know, asked me and a few other hackers is, like,
you know, how do you guys avoid the dark side?
You know, like, how do you say good hackers?
And I was, I personally, I was so offended by that
because, like, all I want to do is go and figure out
how the systems work and break them.
It's like, I don't care what your social security number is,
you know?
Yeah, yeah.
No, that makes sense.
Yeah, how do you not commit credit card fraud?
What's going on?
Yeah, yeah.
And I'm like, maybe that's what you want to do.
And, like, that's, you know,
but that's not why I'm here.
Yeah, no.
And I think that speaks largely to the curiosity-motivated aspect of,
and I think that's one of the things that makes you
a really great researcher and a really great book,
Donnie Hunter.
But it does come with that downside, like you mentioned,
of, like, all right, I'm going to read this thing
until my eyes bleed, you know?
And, like, and try to figure out, you know,
never letting go of a bug, especially, you know,
if you can't figure out,
if you can't explain everything in the situation.
Yeah, I love the term accidentally secure.
Yeah.
Because there's things that I'll come across where, like,
I hate that term.
I love it, but I hate it.
I know things are broken in some way,
but in bug bounty context,
you can only report things that are valid.
You know, you can't report, like, half a bug, really.
Well, you could, but you'd get.
Yeah.
So along that line, like,
how do you go about sort of thinking about bugs
when you're approaching a problem
and you want to, like, really deep dive
and, like, find sort of the most impact?
What is, like, what is your thought process?
I honestly,
and I think you guys have seen this at some recent events,
it's like, I'm really interested in looking for locations
where you can get the highest CVSS score.
I think it's the best way to describe it.
Like, looking for those unauthenticated places
with, you know, networks unauthenticated,
no privileges required.
Aim for that CVSS 10.0
and avoid the places where, like,
you can't possibly get that.
You know, I hate to say it,
but, like, mobile apps come to mind.
Wow.
Shots fired.
But no, at the same time,
like, mobile apps should have a separate,
in my opinion, anyway,
should be rewarded differently.
Yeah.
No, totally.
I totally agree.
We actually had this problem recently as well
where we were trying to award a mobile vulnerability
and trying to figure out how to score it.
And, like, if you go traditional CVSS,
you run into all these problems
where it's, like, you know,
like, adjacency is, like, physical
or, like, local, right?
It's, like, it's really, like,
it's very, very difficult
to score in the same way.
But, like, do you actually approach it,
like, from a CVSS perspective,
like, purely?
Do you just go sort of, like,
okay, like, if I were to think about this from CVSS,
like, what parts of the app should I avoid?
Or is it more sort of, like, high level?
I mean, to be fair,
that's where I'll start.
Okay.
You know, from there,
I'll kind of, like, work my way down.
Yeah.
But it's, yeah,
you know, at the end of the day,
it's, like, we're all trying to,
like, as bug hunters anyways,
we're trying to maximize reward.
Yeah.
That's how we do it.
And it's, like, you know,
this kind of reminds me of a talk
I gave a while back on, you know,
open source methodology
when I was talking about the Grafana bug
at NahamCon.
It's this concept of, like,
okay, I've got this goal, you know,
and I need to work back from where,
you know, let's say I want to submit a,
you know, a 10.0 CVSS bug, right?
Which we all do in bug bounty
and also specifically in live hacking events.
Then you've got to start naturally
from the spots where it's possible
for you to get a, you know,
a 10.0 CVSS bug, right?
So it makes more sense
to focus on the unauthenticated context.
And actually, I had a little bit
of a question here.
It seems to me, like,
in the live hacking event
that we collaborated on,
I'll say it,
but we're going to have to bleep it.
That, you know,
you focused a lot on authentication there
and you focused a lot on authentication
at the last couple of live hacking events
that I've seen you on.
Is that, would you say
that's your bread and butter?
I mean, where does that play a role
in your testing?
You know, I always say
it's where I'm going to start.
And I just often never move on.
That's a lot of the truth to it.
It's like, I'll spend, like,
you know, next thing I'll know
is it'll be like 20, 30 hours later.
And I'm like, I'm still trying
to figure out all the pieces
and understand how they all mesh together.
So when you find yourself down
like a rabbit hole like that,
do you find it's more that just like
you've sort of stumbled into the fact
that the app is more complicated
than you initially realized?
Or do you keep coming up
with like new, more creative scenarios
that you have to sort of suss out
and see if they're, you know,
viable vulnerabilities?
I mean, it's a little bit of both,
but like, you know,
listening to kind of going back
to like listening to this podcast
while I'm like doing other things,
like there's a lot of times
where, you know,
I'll spend like an entire night
just looking at like a single,
like a single piece of the application
and then, you know,
go and brush my teeth
and be like, oh, I'm an idiot.
You know, I need to go back there
and try these things.
I didn't quite realize
this is how they all fit together.
And yeah, that's often led
to my best bugs.
So it's been, you know,
it seems like, you know,
to use the technical terms
is funny because my wife
always gets on my case,
you know, for using technical terms
for like non-technical things.
But it's almost like, you know,
you've got like a, you know,
like a, like a, what's the,
oh, a screen, you know,
like in the terminal, you know,
like it's running in the back
of your brain, you know,
just like, all right,
let me just screen detach
from that, right?
And it's just running back there,
like processing, processing, processing.
And I think you see that
with a lot of top Bugani hunters
is like, even if you're walking away,
you know, from the screen,
when you're doing stuff
like brushing your teeth
or like changing your clothes
or like, you know, you're thinking,
you're thinking you're in that mode.
And it gets overwhelming, right?
Like that's something
that really takes a lot of,
a lot of the parts of your life.
And as somebody who's not
a full-time Bug Bounty hunter,
somebody who has a full-time job,
I'm wondering how you manage that,
you know, with your full-time job
and with Bug Bounty
and like, you know,
how does that affect your life
and how do you segment Bug Bounty
from these other things to,
because it kind of like
tries to take over sometimes, I think.
I mean, it's a really good question.
I mean, to be honest, I don't do it.
I don't do too much Bug Bounty work anymore.
I used to participate
in every life hacking event.
And like, you know, as,
you know, my, my partner was off
finishing off her PhD for a while.
And that just gave me
a little bit more free time
because she was off finishing that.
And so, you know, really since then,
I've had significantly less time from that.
I will say though, it's like,
for me anyways,
it was most challenging
to not associate time spent elsewhere
with like a dollars per hour.
Like, yeah,
you have to be really careful.
Like once you start doing this
with any consistency,
you start getting paid
with any consistency
that you don't associate your time
with an hourly rate.
Because all of a sudden, like,
and honestly, to be clearly honest,
I still have a lot of trouble
listening out and watching TV.
Like, yeah, that's just the challenge.
Totally.
Because like,
I'll start thinking like,
oh, hey, like,
you know, I actually,
I call this,
I call it like,
it's almost like a metronome
in the back of my head.
That's like, you know,
tick, tick, tick.
So I call it like a tick almost.
Like, yeah, yeah.
You know, you should be doing this.
Like, why are you hanging out
with your friends?
You should be going making money.
Like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so like to have,
you have to,
to me anyways,
it's important to
not even try and calculate that.
Because once I start going down that route,
it's, it can really drive me
to immediate outcomes.
It's a slippery slope for sure.
You know, we talked about it,
you know,
on the episode a little bit
with Douglas,
with Douglas Day,
with Archangel.
And he, you know,
he was saying,
yeah, like now I'm trying,
trying to find it hard
to like justify,
you know,
going out with my friends
instead of staying home
and hacking,
you know,
when you have this essentially
unlimited access
to trade your time
for, for money,
that's not really limited.
And sometimes it's like
huge amounts of money.
I mean, to be fair,
it's a good problem.
Like, it's a very privileged
problem to have.
It is.
And, and, and I'm grateful for it.
But, you know,
when you swing it the other way,
it's a little bit,
you know,
it becomes destructive.
And so it's hard
for bug bounty hunters
to, to regulate that for sure.
Um, definitely a pitfall
to be aware of.
So, so jumping back
to the, the,
the hacking methodology thing,
I'm wondering,
you know,
being a deep diving hacker,
I kind of get crap
all the time,
uh, from the community
for like, yeah,
you know,
I'll spend like three weeks,
four weeks on a program,
you know,
before I like move on.
I'm wondering,
I'm looking for some validation
here.
No,
uh, how long do you spend
on a program
and how long do you,
uh, how deep do you dive?
You know,
but also,
again,
let me caveat that question
though,
because I know that,
you know,
the brain works a little better
for Mr.
Sam or compared to,
to me.
So it may not take you
quite as long to,
to get through a target,
but.
I have,
I don't know.
So when it comes to
live hacking events,
especially,
I will look at that target,
nothing but that target
for that time period
and then just stop completely.
Um,
for other targets,
I will actually come back
to them,
especially targets that
I'll submit a bug
and they'll react to it quickly.
Like that's been my test.
It's like,
if I submit a bug,
they react to it quickly.
Like, okay,
like this,
this team isn't going to have
like too many,
uh,
duplicates sitting around
for me to find.
Um,
they're quick to respond,
which means like
I can go and submit other things
and not,
not be worried
that they're going to like,
I don't know,
maybe not pay me
or something,
for example.
Um,
sure.
But honestly,
there've been very few
private targets
that I've like really stuck with.
Um,
Airbnb was one that I,
um,
and I think we,
we actually participated
in that life hacking event
together.
Yes,
we did,
Sam.
Yes,
we did.
And I,
I,
yeah.
Okay.
I took first at that event,
but somehow somebody else
got the belt.
So,
love that.
Um,
no,
we'll dive into that later.
I'm sorry.
Continue.
Uh,
Airbnb was one where it's like,
I,
I found that I really liked
how their application worked
and,
um,
you know,
so I,
I did the extra stuff there.
I even automated everything
that I could.
Um,
and I really stuck with that
for years until they
made some like pretty high level.
They actually wrote a whole
engineering blog post on,
on this.
And it was like more of like
an engineering change,
but it also resulted in like
a really positive security outcome
where like all of their security
became much more centralized
and really bug prone.
That's what I described it.
Um,
dude,
can you talk a little bit about that?
Like now that the blog post is out,
can you talk about some of the details
of what they changed
and,
and how,
this is entirely from an
outside perspective.
Like,
I don't know the like,
you know,
insider details of any of this,
obviously.
Um,
but you know,
they,
without,
I'm trying to like not talk
about bug reports.
Sorry.
Um,
you're good.
Uh,
they centralized,
seemingly centralized a lot
of their,
I'm sorry,
good.
Yeah.
Well,
for what it's worth,
if you want to talk about
some bug reports,
we can always like cut it out
and bleep it later.
So that just makes it easier.
Yeah.
Oh no,
it's all good.
I really think like what it
comes down to is like,
they really centralized their,
um,
off management and that really like
putting that all into one place
and like centralizing control
of all of their API endpoints,
um,
really led to,
it was really,
it seems like it was more
of an engineering decision,
you know,
like it probably led to good
engineering outcomes,
but the side effect was like,
you didn't have teams going off
and making their own APIs
with the same mistakes
over and over again.
Um,
so,
you know,
that's after that,
I kind of stopped.
What is the,
so what does that mean,
Sam?
Like,
like if we were to,
if we were to take it a little,
another layer,
you know,
clearer,
is that saying,
okay,
you know,
they implemented some middleware
that sits on front of all the API
endpoints that implements,
you know,
their access control stuff
and all of the IDORs disappeared
or are we talking about off?
I mean,
is that,
is that really what we're talking about?
Okay.
Yeah.
So like,
I don't want to get through that one,
didn't I?
No,
I mean,
like we can say that Airbnb had IDORs,
you know,
it's not,
that's not the end of the world.
Um,
no,
and that's big,
you know?
And so when you see a giant change like that,
you know,
that changed the way that you interacted with that,
with that program.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
it's a good security outcome for them.
Um,
you know,
we're obviously,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're both simultaneously like security driven,
but we're also monetarily driven.
So it's like,
yeah,
obviously it resulted in me getting paid less money,
but it also means Airbnb being more secure.
So how long did you spend on that program?
Uh,
oh,
I mean,
I automated,
everything I could,
um,
probably 5,200 hours.
Okay.
And is that over the course of six months?
Is that over the course of a couple of weeks?
A few months.
Yeah.
Okay.
And what does automation for that sort of thing look like?
Everything was custom.
Um,
you know,
I was,
I was writing custom parsers for their JavaScript to pull out API endpoints,
testing those API endpoints.
Um,
I,
were you automatically testing the API endpoints or were you alerting on them,
then manually text on testing?
Just manually learning to be fair,
but,
um,
there was,
there was some automation there.
Uh,
then there was also,
um,
I've gone through a series of like revisions of my own,
like recon architecture.
Um,
some of which I ended up open sourcing.
but,
uh,
I,
that was,
I don't think I saw that.
Is that on your GitHub?
Uh,
I don't actually know if I ever,
uh,
well,
I mean,
part of it was,
that was the whole like DNS crap thing.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
DNS crap.
Of course.
Uh,
so that's just like,
you know,
you can take advantage of,
uh,
you know,
DNS is hierarchical.
You can search it really easily based on that.
Um,
as long as you pre-start it.
Yeah.
I was going to ask.
So like two things on that one,
you mentioned that you wrote like very custom automation.
Um,
obviously that's a little bit easier when you have a software engineering
background,
but it was that something sort of like that you decided to do because you
were spending a lot of time on Airbnb or do you do that for every
program or like what,
what,
what made you do that?
I freaking probably wrote it in C.
To be fair,
it was using like four languages,
but yeah.
No C in there.
What?
I'm not,
I don't even want to know.
Get out.
You're off the pot.
Not allowed.
Oh,
geez.
No,
I just,
you know,
I tried to use the right thing for the right purpose.
Like,
you know,
I just string everything together with bash,
but like where I need to,
I'll drop into like go line to just get things faster.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not quite at rest yet,
but I'll get there eventually.
Yeah.
Well,
few of us are.
Um,
no,
that makes sense.
And actually JS monitoring,
is something that we've been talking about a lot in the,
you know,
critical thinking community lately.
And there've been some really cool solutions that are coming up around it.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's exciting to see.
And,
you know,
you were kind of ahead of the,
of the curve on this industry,
you know,
doing this back in what,
I mean,
when did we compete at that event?
Was that 2018?
2019?
Yeah.
2019 maybe.
Um,
so,
you know,
what,
what was that?
I mean,
let me just try to break it down technically.
So you would,
you would reach out to the,
you know,
uh,
HTML page,
pull out the JavaScript file hash,
go to that JavaScript file.
Would you beautify it?
Or would you just run regex on it?
Or were you,
were you doing diffs of,
of the code directly?
Or were you doing diffs of like the strings in the code?
How did that look?
Um,
if I recall correctly,
it was like a,
I think my pack is the right term to be using there.
Yeah.
So reach out to Airbnb,
pull out the web pack.
Uh,
they followed,
and I,
once again,
this is pushing those.
Yeah.
It's a little bit.
It's a little farther back too.
yeah.
Um,
they would,
uh,
follow a very common format for their API endpoints in that web pack,
even though it was somewhat minified,
um,
which you could then pretty,
be straightforward to extract that.
And yeah,
I mean,
from there,
it's all just like discord notifications.
Like,
Hey,
there's this new thing.
And,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's a really easy way to,
when you,
when you know a program,
well,
it can become a very easy way to find bugs.
Um,
because as soon as something launches,
you can just be like,
okay,
I'm just going to test it,
you know,
and you're off to the first one there.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
I mean,
this is what the pros are doing,
you know,
when you're,
when you're going long-term,
going deep on a program.
And,
and that actually makes me think a little bit for,
you know,
more,
obviously you were sort of taking notes with code in this
scenario,
right?
You were,
you were saying,
okay,
I've noticed this structure in the JS file on how these API
endpoints are,
you know,
done.
I'm going to write some code to automatically parse all this and,
you know,
uh,
help me see this in a better way.
But I'm wondering what kind of notes do you take for
yourself in general?
Are you like,
uh,
you know,
whatever,
asked of dot txt sort of guy,
or are you like,
uh,
I've got this whole postman built out with their whole API
spec sort of guy.
Um,
yeah,
I did,
I did hear that in the last episode.
That's why.
Yeah.
It's not for me.
I actually take,
I have like a pretty standardized format at this point for
recon.
I think all my recon is up in his own folder.
Everything is very,
very neat there.
And I can even diff it between like runs,
um,
to see what's great.
But when it comes to like looking at the application itself,
no,
I,
yeah,
I'm a read me dot txt guy.
Yeah.
Sure.
Next time.
Next time I have on this dot txt.
Yeah.
I mean,
like,
what do you think about that though?
Like just out of curiosity,
you know,
we all have the things that we do,
because we,
that's just how we do it.
Yeah.
But,
but do you think it'd be more optimal for you to take time to,
to,
to write,
you know,
more thorough notes?
Or do you think that would interrupt the creative process or what?
I think,
you know,
I think it really depends.
Like,
I think it's like,
it's easier.
Maybe case again,
like,
I think like if I were to spend more time on that program,
then yeah,
I would absolutely have taken much more structured notes on that.
And I have a lot of respect to folks who do.
And like,
I don't know.
That's something I wish I,
or I should get better at.
Yeah.
There's definitely room for growth.
I mean,
I thought I had structured notes and then even,
even still,
I've seen some other people who have like way,
way more structured notes that I'm like,
I'm looking at theirs and I'm like,
dang,
that's I,
I need to make some improvements.
And then every time I go back to mine,
I'm like,
eh,
it would be a lot better if I,
if I had,
you know,
X,
Y,
and Z.
But,
um,
this is one of those things that is,
is sometimes it's a real big time investment.
And,
uh,
depending on like what your workflow looks like,
like if it's not like a bump in your workflow,
then oftentimes it's just better to just,
you know,
keep it simple.
And.
Yeah.
I think it was,
I think it was the,
uh,
the interview with France,
which like,
I don't know,
I feel kind of honored to have to go in after him.
A little star truck.
Big shoes to fill.
Um,
but,
uh,
he,
he talked about how he was like,
uh,
you know,
taking,
taking notes of like parameters used and stuff.
And it's like,
I almost wish I had even like a whole nother layer of structured recon.
Um,
it's usually I,
uh,
for the most part anyways,
I tend to stop with like sub-invian enumeration a little bit past that,
but like not too much.
And like,
I really think that there's so much that could be out of there.
Um,
that would,
you know,
at the end of the day,
just like make,
make the bug hunters life easier,
so to speak.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a lot of,
uh,
extra layers you can go down deep and when you get,
start getting diminishing returns,
I don't know.
And it actually makes me,
makes me think of this,
this topic,
um,
this sort of hypothesis that I've been kind of thinking about,
thinking about lately because,
you know,
us three,
we've all been successful in bug bounty.
And,
you know,
when you start building a discord community,
like we are at critical thinking,
you get a lot of people being like,
Hey,
you know,
this is what I want to do.
Can you,
can you help me get there?
And I,
and we don't have time to answer all the questions,
but I,
it has made me think more about how to framework eyes,
what I do.
Right.
And,
and how to like take away life lessons from something that I just kind of do
intuitively.
Right.
Um,
and one of the things that came to my mind is I wonder whether bug bounty
hunting can be minimized to,
or simplified,
I guess,
to number of attack vectors tried.
Like,
I wonder if,
if there was a way for us to optimize our hunting for just raw number of
attack vectors tried,
whether that would be close to the optimal path to produce,
uh,
you know,
bugs as the result.
Like,
like,
am I,
am I off base yet?
What do I,
I think you're off base.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
That's great.
That's good.
Good.
I love it.
It would just,
it would just dominate that chart.
Right.
The,
the,
what,
what would dominate that chart?
Say it again.
Oh yeah.
No,
no.
Yeah.
I mean like,
well,
what do you,
what do you mean by that?
Cause I mean like,
okay,
you know,
I'm going to try if I can do this ID or on this one end point.
No.
Okay.
And you know,
I'm going to do,
try to do this,
you know,
uh,
sea surf over here.
You know,
like the more attack vectors I'm trying,
the more likelihood one of them is going to work.
Right.
And,
and so,
but I guess this is sort of like a approach.
No,
no,
this is a gambler's fallacy right here.
Okay.
All right.
Hit me.
The more attack vectors you try the equally likely they are for,
for them to pop.
Okay.
It's a flip of a coin every single time.
There's no guarantee.
But it's not though.
Like it's not really.
Well,
abstract,
like from it abstractly.
Yes.
There's no,
like every vulnerability has an equal chance of,
of,
of occurring depending on the context and you with your intuition as a
hunter,
you can determine what things are more likely.
That's what I'm talking about.
So I think that that's like,
like the real nuance is that the more that you've been hacking,
the more you're able to narrow,
like quickly narrow down your scope of vulnerabilities that you're
testing based on what you're seeing.
Whereas theoretically there's infinite possibilities,
right?
Like you,
you could test infinite variations of IDORS and vulnerabilities in all
different parameters and everything,
and never hit anything because you're sort of blindly testing the wrong
things when you should be doing what you're doing,
which is narrowly targeting it down.
Yeah.
And so I've actually,
I've,
this has like a lot of parallel with,
um,
like binary reverse engineering.
Um,
and like the,
the,
the thing I've heard there anyways,
it's like,
I'm not great at this myself,
but like,
we're going to get some Sam Herb shit right now,
dude,
this is about to be,
once you figure out,
uh,
this is from,
this is,
I probably saw this on Twitter at some point,
but like,
once you understand,
like what a printf function looks like,
you know,
you see it and you can,
uh,
cast it aside as like,
this is a printf function.
I don't need to look at this again.
Um,
that absolutely happens in this industry.
you know,
I know what this framework looks like,
or I know this is a WordPress site,
and I'm just going to cast it aside or look at extensions and that's it,
you know,
for example.
Um,
but that first time you see something,
it's like,
yeah,
you have to like put in the time to like understand it.
And like going back to what you were saying,
like looking for the,
um,
trying to understand what the,
what the,
or what the quickest way is to find bugs.
I really think like having a way to search or categorize your past reports
would go a long way towards that,
but then you have to have that catalog past reports.
Um,
you know,
and this,
it comes up with me actually a lot with,
uh,
um,
XXE type bugs,
like that whole,
any,
any variant of an XXE,
um,
over time,
I've kind of built up like a catalog of like past reports.
And it's like,
it's very easy to just go in there and find working exploits.
But if you search on the internet,
it's,
you know,
they might work,
they might not work.
They might only work in certain contexts.
Um,
and so you kind of develop this catalog of things you found and therefore can just
leverage that to go find again.
Yeah.
No,
that,
that makes sense.
And,
and specifically on targets,
you know,
like you mentioned with the Airbnb thing,
I mean,
some targets are just going to be vulnerable to the same thing over and over and
over again,
just by nature of their software development life cycle and their,
you know,
inner culture decisions on how to do,
authentication and,
and authorization and that sort of thing.
Right.
Um,
and so that's definitely good advice.
And,
and,
and I guess what I mean a little bit,
just going back to the whole volume of attack vectors sort of vibe,
like,
I don't mean to,
I still think this methodology could be helpful for beginners because the,
it's so easy to get lost in,
in all the things you need to study,
you know,
and all the things you need to understand.
And,
and,
but I really liked your,
your,
your scenario of like,
we all needed to test a WordPress site,
you know,
a couple of times before we knew that,
ah,
the volumes are going to be in the extensions,
you know?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
And so,
I don't know,
it's kind of a hard thing to,
to normalize because I feel like there should be some way to,
you know,
get the 80,
20 rule out of this,
right?
Like,
you know,
like for us to be really thorough on a target,
like we are in the live hacking events,
you've got to really go 100%.
But in order to find 80% of the bugs,
you know,
with 20% of the effort,
there should be some sort of algorithm that,
that,
that should lead us down that path.
But it's not optimizing for attack vectors.
I can see,
because,
because that does make sense,
Joel,
that,
you know,
you could just endlessly test a bunch of random things.
So,
I don't know.
It's hard to nail down.
Yeah,
it's definitely,
it's definitely a tricky thing.
I think like a lot of different automation stuff has tried to sort of capture that where like,
whether it's like the DNS,
like a lot of that,
I'd say like 80%,
like probably maybe not 80%,
but maybe like 60% is like DNS recon,
subdomain takeovers,
like simple XSS is like vulnerable software that's been deployed that is online.
Like there's a lot of that stuff.
That's just like easy,
sort of low hanging fruit that all you have to do is find it in order to exploit,
exploit it.
Um,
and then the rest is like sort of like authenticated testing,
like having to go deep,
having to like actually understand the,
the,
the relationships between different parts of the application and identify how you can,
you know,
leverage that or exploit it to,
to pop oftentimes the same types of bugs,
but just in a different context.
Um,
I don't know,
man.
I just think there's something to be said for volume as well.
You know,
like there's something to be said for,
okay,
you know,
I'm going to just go and try all the things I can think of,
but maybe that's,
that's not the exact,
exact approach.
All right.
Well,
let me,
let's move along from a classic Justin tangent there.
I'll continue to keep on noodling on.
I know I'm about to have a 30 minute debate with Justin about this after,
after he knows,
he knows what's coming,
man.
Um,
yeah,
you know,
I don't know.
I feel like there should be some way,
but Joel,
we'll,
we'll save this for a,
uh,
for a time when we can really,
hash this one out.
Um,
so one of the things that I,
that I wanted to ask,
I guess,
it's sort of tangentially related to the,
to the debate that we just had there on,
on how to optimize for bugs is,
do you think you,
and this is kind of a gut feeling I've been wanting to ask a bunch of the
people that come on the pod,
how much of your time do you think you spend thinking about the bug versus
actually testing something?
So let's say you've got a scenario where you're,
where you've got like a,
a bug you're trying to exploit,
right?
Do you often just sit back,
stare at the ceiling,
think about the bug,
or do you,
are you constantly iterating and trying new things and brute forcing this and,
you know,
that sort of thing.
If you had to guess,
what would your ratios be of between those two?
It's really terrible.
So I spend far too much time throwing everything I think of at bugs.
Like I know I'm in trouble when I start going into burp and like using the,
the hex fields to send a valid character through.
Like that means I'm probably at a little bit too deep.
Yeah.
But,
but then like I'll more often than not,
like when things aren't like super obvious,
I'll find bugs when I'm not,
when I'm starting to see,
you know,
or equivalent like that,
stepping back for me anyways,
and thinking about how the system works and like,
you know,
thinking about the system as a whole,
often the lead system of the better findings that I've had,
you know,
you're at the end of the day,
it's like,
you're trying to,
you're trying to outsmart a lot of other people who are thinking about this
security and like,
yeah,
you're not,
you have your own unique perspective,
but like,
that's,
that's also like something that other people are going to consider
potentially.
It's like,
you have to find your angle,
but then also like,
but also like find a way to find something unique.
So,
so on that topic,
do you have any like sort of tips that you like to use when,
so like the way that I'm thinking about this is basically,
if I was hitting a dead wall or a brick wall,
oftentimes what I would try and do is figure out like,
what is the backend running?
Or like,
how do,
how do I identify more parts of this infrastructure?
Do you have any things that you like to do?
Like,
you know,
you just like sort of your go-to things that you like to try and throw in
there to see if you can figure out more about the stack?
Yeah.
And like,
I,
one of my favorite things to try and do is to try and understand how their
development environment works.
Like I'll go and find that development environment,
find their origin servers,
like see if I can get access to those and poke around and see if things can
get reflected into prod or vice versa.
just understand more about their deployment environment,
but then also like their development environment and even like search on
GitHub,
for example,
for not,
not for secrets,
so to speak,
but just for like development related things.
For data.
Yeah.
For knowledge.
Just,
just anything you could find that would like,
you know,
you find somewhere like on GitHub,
like a random IP address that happens to be the origin server.
And like that,
yeah,
that can be huge.
Like that can be all you need for certain bugs.
Yeah,
dude.
See,
I love this so much.
This is,
this is,
this is great because listen to the way Sam talked about that,
right?
He said,
I want,
I want to learn more about the development environment.
So I go and find the dev servers.
Right.
And,
and that's not,
Sam is not looking at those dev servers as like a separate entity of
sorts,
right.
In this,
in this whole system,
he's looking at it as a part of the whole,
right.
And you,
you know,
you can use that,
that,
that extra piece,
right.
To give you knowledge about prod,
or you can find this little piece,
of data on GitHub that can,
when you actually read the source code and you look at the open source
libraries that they have,
that they're no doubt using in their own platform,
right.
Um,
can give you all the little pieces you need to,
to get deeper and deeper and deeper.
That's,
that's such great advice,
Sam.
Well,
yeah.
And that's also been like how you'll find like a lot of shared
secrets between development and production and like,
yeah,
development will be as locked down.
And so you just get access to the secrets more often than not,
you know,
or,
there's also been bugs where it's like,
kind of like what you're talking about,
they're using something open source,
but that open source library happens to use like a static secret
somewhere.
Like,
yeah,
that's very common.
Yeah.
I actually,
man,
where was it?
I saw recently,
you found something that had a static secret.
It was like a,
a GitHub,
a security issue that I saw pop up somewhere.
I was like,
where'd it go,
Sam?
Yeah.
Um,
I don't remember what product it was on,
but I'll,
I'll look it up afterwards and link it.
I know what you're talking about.
I don't recall.
It sounds like,
yeah,
you're going to have to be more specific,
Justin.
That happens to me every day.
Um,
it was earlier this year and I just don't recall the product.
Oh,
that's terrible.
No,
you're good.
Um,
yeah.
So I guess the last thing that I wanted to kind of talk to you about in
sort of the hacker methodology section,
um,
collaboration,
right?
What,
what role,
I mean,
obviously we've collaborated together and,
you know,
collaborating with Justin special,
special experience there.
Uh,
but,
but talk to me about,
about,
talk to me about,
about collaboration,
how it works in with your methodology,
how it motivates you or how it,
um,
you know,
makes you perform different in a live hacking event or even just in a bug
bounty context.
Yeah.
Like the people that I collaborate with,
more often than not,
it's like,
I don't know.
I,
I ended up putting like higher,
higher expectations on myself than the other person.
Like,
yeah,
I don't want to collaborate unless I know I can give like 110% to that
target.
I've noticed that you do that.
I love collaborating with you,
Sam.
I just,
I just won't even recommend it.
Like if I'm like,
I don't know if I'm like off doing something else,
I'll be like,
yeah,
no,
sorry.
I just can't like,
yeah.
It's not because I,
I really respect that you have,
that like boundary though.
For,
for me,
I have this really bad habit of just saying yes to like everything.
So,
so here I am,
it's December.
I currently have about 15 side projects going on and,
and I'll be doing three of them today.
Sam,
it seems like you've got some healthy boundaries,
man,
in place with bug bounty,
which is cool.
It used to be less healthy.
Yeah.
Well,
can you talk a little bit about that?
Because,
you know,
to be fair,
I think we had a conversation about this a little bit,
you know,
you've been in,
you've been in this,
uh,
you know,
tech world a little longer than,
than some of us hackers have.
And you,
you,
uh,
no,
but I mean,
you've,
you've told me some,
you,
you've told me some stuff that I,
you know,
that I appreciated.
And that,
that,
you know,
you've learned from,
from the,
the wisdom of being in the industry for a little bit longer.
How have you,
I guess,
gotten bug bounty to a point where you have a better work life balance with it and,
uh,
you know,
a better relationship with bug bounty and are able to control those sort of obsessive tendencies,
right?
Because it,
it doesn't seem like you're,
you're,
and maybe it's,
it's just by,
by virtue of the fact that you're not in it every single day because you,
you know,
have a full-time job and you kind of distance yourself from it in that regard.
But,
um,
I know you also have,
you know,
a family and that sort of thing and,
and you have other responsibilities there.
And I'm just wondering how it all gets balanced or if there's any tips you've learned along the way.
I mean,
for me,
the biggest thing is like,
I,
I've stopped,
I've stopped looking at a lot of random programs.
I think it's probably the best way to describe it.
Like I used to,
you know,
every invite I used to be like,
oh,
I'll poke at this.
And now it's like,
you know,
you get that invite and it's like,
well,
okay,
like if I have time for this,
you know,
or like,
um,
but then like,
I will try and like,
when I do choose to do like a life hacking event or like,
you know,
especially some of the,
um,
like U S government related to bounty stuff.
It's like,
when those come up,
it's like,
okay,
like I'm going to make a point to like set time aside for this.
Like,
you know,
let folks in my life know,
especially like,
I'm going to be spending these nights,
like doing this thing.
And like,
especially when you're married.
Yeah.
You've got that,
that level of,
you know,
communication you've got to,
got to get through or else it's not going to work.
Yeah.
And like,
you're like,
I'm going to work all day and then do this all night.
Like you probably won't see me too much.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
It's like that.
Or maybe you shouldn't say it like that.
Maybe you should say,
Hey,
sweetie,
you know,
what did you think if I tried to earn a little extra money?
Yeah.
No.
And I mean,
like,
I don't know.
You,
you also like,
I remember the first,
the first bounty I got and this is like the first,
like hack the Pentagon thing.
And it was like $150.
I was like,
this is wild.
Like I've never seen so much money before in my life.
You know?
And now it's like,
ah,
yeah.
You know,
like,
I guess I'll respond to this thing.
Cause it's going to earn me another $500 or something.
Yeah.
It's become very,
it's both being jaded,
but then also like,
yeah.
Disassociating.
Yeah.
The bug bounty space with the money to some extent.
Which a hundred percent.
Like,
I don't know.
We're earning good money here.
Yeah.
You know,
we're in,
we're in a good position to be able to say no to certain things too,
as well.
Dude.
That's so good.
Yeah.
Like,
like having the,
and I think that's a part of the guttural response of,
you know,
being successful in,
in book bounty in the beginning is like,
ah,
I just got a bounty.
Like maybe I can do this more.
And,
you know,
and you're just like sort of constantly chasing that hit of the,
the,
you know,
of like the bounty,
right.
It's almost like a gambling thing.
Right.
And,
and,
but once you learn to control that,
once you,
you know,
and I,
and I talk about this as a little,
a little bit as well as like,
for me,
it was a part of an identity thing for me.
Like,
ah,
like I haven't fulfilled my,
identity that I,
that I want,
you know,
to be who I want to be.
If I'm not,
you know,
at the top of the leaderboard,
every event,
you know,
that sort of thing.
Right.
And just kind of redefining that away has helped me,
um,
build some healthy boundaries.
And it sounds like for you,
you know,
saying no to some opportunities,
whether it be a private program invite,
or maybe even a live hacking event that you just,
you can't make it work right now.
It's not going to be healthy.
Saying no to those things have kind of helped you,
you build a more healthy relationship with bug bounty.
Yeah.
And it's also,
I mean,
to be fair,
one of the benefits of like having a full-time job and kind of doing this like nights and weekends is like you do,
you can just pause.
Like there's,
you still have health insurance.
And I know you've talked about this as well.
It's,
yeah,
there are,
there are ways around this in the U S.
Um,
but like,
you know,
self-health insurance,
you're still about paycheck coming in,
like your bills are still paid.
Yeah,
it's good.
And that's,
it's nice to have that.
Miss those days.
I mean,
to,
to a degree I do,
you know,
and I love the day to day,
but for me,
you know,
as a full-time hunter,
what that looks like is like realizing,
okay,
I don't actually have to be working all the time because the payoff,
you know,
the risk is greater and the reward is greater,
you know?
Um,
and so,
you know,
if I need to take a couple of days here and there to like decompress and
chill and,
you know,
not be working constantly,
then I,
I should be able to do that.
But,
you know,
I'll,
I'll let you know whenever I figure that out.
Um,
all right,
man.
So that was a lot of the hacking methodology stuff.
Um,
let's,
let's jump back and look,
look at the career a little bit because,
um,
you know,
this podcast is primarily about bug bounty stuff.
Um,
and we'll definitely come back to more about bounty stuff,
but I also,
I'm the host of this podcast and I have some very,
I'm very interested in,
uh,
you know,
career development and entrepreneurialism in particular.
So I'd really like to talk to you about your career.
And then also the whole thing that you did with,
um,
uh,
buffer over dot run,
um,
and that whole experience.
So,
uh,
start from wherever you'd like with the career thing.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I was,
um,
kind of going back a little bit undergrad.
I was,
uh,
computer system engineering.
I think Joel was as well,
right?
Uh,
well I was,
yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
Security engine engineering.
I had a security engineering major when,
when I went into college.
So,
um,
yeah.
So I'm just going to stop you right there.
I,
I didn't know how to say that without making you sound old.
No,
no,
no.
I'm going to stop you right there.
So computer engineering versus computer science versus whatever the heck Joel did.
Um,
what,
what are your thoughts on that?
And what are the ways you think it's impacted your career?
I,
so I actually dual majored with math and I thought I was going to be a cryptographer.
Yeah.
And I found that the computers engineering courses were pretty straightforward and I really struggled
with the math courses.
So I was like,
I should go and do this computer thing.
Um,
but you know,
honestly,
I think like really any of these will give you a good background.
Um,
you know,
I think that that's like learning the fundamentals will get you a lot of the way to being able
to like really easily pivot into bug bounty,
the bug bounty sites,
if you want to,
um,
you know,
for me,
like starting bug bounty stuff was less about learning the security side of it and more
about learning how verb suite worked.
Yeah.
I totally see like so many people who are like technology adjacent who are like,
I don't know how to get started.
And it's like,
do you see something you don't know what it is?
Just look it up and like start following every rabbit hole that you see.
And that's the best way to get started.
It's just like,
you take one step and just like slide down the hill.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and also like you said,
Sam,
you know,
but it can also,
you see a lot of people that aren't technical,
which is know how to use burp suite and know how to find IDORs and know,
you know,
have a basic understanding.
Yeah.
Of how the browser works.
Right.
You know,
and you'll find your XSS is your,
your IDORs,
your C-serves,
your,
you know,
access control issues.
And that's more than enough to pay the bills.
If you know those four VULM types,
IDOR,
XSS,
C-serve,
access control,
or client side implementation of access controls.
I mean,
you can make a lot of money.
Yeah.
And another thing that you can do is you can kind of target those as well.
So you can like,
if you say you work in some industry,
that's like maybe a little more obscure,
but it's still technology adjacent.
You probably have experience interfacing with some software that like most people don't use.
And so you can probably find vulnerabilities in that way better than other people can,
because you're used to this software.
You might even already kind of know a vulnerability and not realize it's a vulnerability.
And it's just like,
oh yeah,
this is kind of like works this way.
And it's like,
probably not supposed to work that way.
Yeah.
So,
so I'd recommend like,
if you,
you know,
if you have experience with that,
with that kind of stuff,
like try and see if they have a program or see if they have a security team and,
you know,
try and find vulnerabilities.
Cause that's also a good place to start.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
Sorry,
sorry,
Sam for the interruption.
I just,
you know,
the computer science versus computer engineering thing is kind of close to my heart because I see,
people like you and Joel that have a little,
bit lower level understanding of some of the stuff that I'm missing.
And I've had to claw that back,
you know,
since I've graduated because my CS program was focused entirely on programming.
It was like 100% programming.
And,
and now I'm like,
I don't really understand some of this lower level stuff.
And I've had to re,
you know,
gain that knowledge as a,
as a professional.
So,
you know,
my advice,
I guess,
to people that want to go to college,
which is a choice in and of itself is,
is to go,
you know,
computer engineering or security engineering,
degree to get that lower level aspect.
Yeah.
And I've always kind of looked at it from like,
you don't,
what you learn there is almost to me anyways,
it was kind of irrelevant to what I actually ended up doing,
but it was more of the exposure to all these like different technologies,
different ways to do things.
And then you can then apply that later.
Like,
you know,
never in my life will I ever write Miss Assembly again,
but I can handle it at some point.
Yeah.
I mean,
but I mean,
that's the,
that's the thing that doesn't make you scared of it though.
Right.
Like if you,
if you talk to a web developer,
right.
Somebody like,
like me years ago,
when,
whenever I was just writing PHP and,
you know,
all that sort of thing and talk about like assembly,
it's like,
ah,
you know,
that's that weird shit.
Like you're,
you're like putting stuff in registers and stuff like that.
Right.
You know,
it's like,
um,
you know,
so it's,
it's intimidating.
And I think exposure to it is one of the things that,
that can help earlier on in your education.
You know,
you don't need to know how to do everything for your job.
Right.
Cause you're going to have to learn a lot of it on,
on the job,
but just that base level exposure,
I think is helpful.
Yeah.
And I will say like getting one thing I wish I had taken more of where
like,
and I don't really even know if these existed back then where like how to
be a software dev type courses.
Cause I think that that would get you much further today than a lot of the
college courses that I took.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
I mean,
if we could switch it and I'll,
I'll trade you the how to,
how to be a software dev stuff from my college and you can give me like,
you know,
OS one to one or something like that.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
uh,
all right.
So,
so college,
um,
computer engineering from there,
where'd you go?
Yeah.
So I went to work at Cisco and,
um,
I was doing like working on like VPN technology,
the ASA firewall VPN aggregator.
Ah,
dude,
you're the one that wrote all that,
buggy code.
That's getting popped every,
I actually wrote almost,
I wrote very minimal amount of code there.
You know,
a lot of the work I was doing were like integrating new platforms and stuff.
Um,
yeah.
Uh,
no,
the folks there,
I mean,
they're brilliant at what they do,
to be honest.
Um,
trying to make all that work all in a single like box is kind of nuts.
but somebody there,
uh,
it was like,
Hey,
like you like security,
you should go to the DEF CON.
Um,
um,
and so I guess actually kind of backing up a little bit even further.
And she's,
this is like dating myself,
but like,
um,
I started listening to the security now podcast,
like right when it first launched.
Yeah,
dude.
Um,
it's twit,
right?
Yep.
It spun out of that.
And like that to me actually got me interested in a lot of this,
um,
into this whole world,
honestly,
because the way that they explained it,
especially in the earlier episodes was like very,
very basic.
So it went back to fundamentals very well there.
And I don't know.
I just have a huge amount of respect for them,
especially because they're still going,
which is just nuts.
Yeah,
dude.
Yeah.
Years later,
man,
it's your podcast.
So gee,
cause that show has been around for forever.
It's like 2004.
I want to say.
Yeah.
I was listening to my guy,
uh,
was it iPod,
iPod mini or something.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Like downloading it over.
That's amazing.
Um,
but anyway,
sorry,
going back to,
so I was at Cisco and I was like,
Hey,
you should go to Defcon.
And it's like,
I went there and,
um,
I was like,
I have no idea what to do.
Like,
I don't really just want to go to a talk.
So I walked into the,
like the puzzle room and Brett was sitting right there.
Ah,
really?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
How nuts is that?
Yeah.
Um,
and,
uh,
yeah.
So we ended up like competing for a few years.
Like we went to get black badges.
Awesome.
Um,
and then he was like,
you know,
I think I helped him.
I don't remember exactly the timeline here,
but at some point I like helped him find like a,
like a zero day RC and Ruby,
like a Ruby library.
Um,
he was like,
Hey,
you should come to these like live hacking events.
Um,
and so I went to one of them and like,
I was like there,
I was like doing anything really like curl commands.
And I was like watching everyone use burp.
And I was like,
what is this magic?
You know,
he's using curl.
He's hacking it with curl.
I remember a similar thing.
When I started bug,
man,
I was using like Charles and everybody's using this thing called burp.
And I was like,
burp,
you guys should try Charles.
And they were like,
well,
it's like,
I know exactly what everyone's doing,
but I just couldn't keep up with them.
You know?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
if you're using curl and,
and fricking inspector or dev tools versus burp,
you're going to be in trouble.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
And so from there,
I was like,
you know,
I think I actually said to,
uh,
nom sec.
And I actually said to him,
this is back when he worked at hacker one.
Um,
I said to him,
I was like,
I'm going to like,
I'm going to get better at this.
I'm going to win one of these events one day.
Um,
that was,
yeah.
Lo and behold.
That was your superhero arc.
I mean,
that's pretty much it to be honest.
You know,
from there,
it's like,
I went to work at,
uh,
Akamai working on like Sotila's,
software.
And then,
um,
I helped start the red team there kind of like part time with my job.
Um,
and that really pivoted me further into the like security engineering world.
and then,
yeah,
a year and a half ago,
I joined Google.
Nice dude.
Yeah,
no,
that that's a good,
that's a good journey.
And so the CTF thing,
you know,
you rolled into DEF CON,
you meet,
you meet Brett,
and then you guys just kind of hit it off and start like popping stuff on CTFs.
That's,
that's the,
that's how you got into that space.
It wasn't as much CTFs as it was like puzzles,
which is like a different world.
Okay.
Um,
but it quickly pivoted into the bug bounty world.
Yeah.
And so talk to me about the black badge thing.
Like that's pretty bad ass for one.
And I think you have multiple or one or.
Yeah.
So our team won two.
Um,
two.
Yeah.
So how,
how did,
how,
like that,
that's so amazing.
And how did,
how did the CTF come about and who's on your team?
Give me the deets.
It was.
In retrospect,
I don't know.
It does like,
doesn't like feel like a real experience,
but like,
you know,
we got a team together of like,
there were 10 to 13 of us.
And these puzzles were put on by,
uh,
lost one zero five seven.
He's like the organizer at DEF CON or was one of the organizers at DEF CON
at the time,
like making the badges and everything.
And so he would put together these puzzles as well.
And,
you know,
our team would compete against other similarly sized teams and we'd spend
nothing.
We do nothing else during DEF CON.
Like that was our DEF CON.
So it was only DEF CON.
Like you,
you show up DEF CON and you get the info and then you start hacking.
Yeah.
I mean,
we would,
we would go as far as like,
we would actually,
you know,
and I think I,
I have actually gave a,
I gave a talk on this.
Um,
part of my TLS recon was scanning the internet for origin,
origin story of the TLS recon was getting the internet for
secrets before.
The DEF CON launch.
Yeah.
Before DEF CON launch.
Like the week before.
You're trying to like find the,
the servers in advance of the,
oh my gosh.
Yeah.
We were successful.
Um,
but,
uh,
it turns out somebody,
so we were monitoring the entire doc codes TLD.
Yeah.
Like everything,
everything.
Yeah.
Every single domain.
And somebody somehow would be a competitor competing teams got wind of
this and they put up a fake puzzle.
And we spent three days solving this.
No.
You know,
email,
email lost and say,
you've won this.
And so we sent him an email.
He's like,
what the hell?
Like this wasn't me.
What the heck?
Yeah.
Wow.
That is some,
that is some gray hat shit right there,
dude.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's nuts.
It's certainly like freaking ARP spoofing people at a live hacking event or
something.
Jeez.
It was three days roughly of our time where we had nothing but saw all these
puzzles.
And like,
to be fair,
it was really well done,
but like they were all faked.
If I was you,
I would have been pissed.
I mean,
we're suppressed by anything else.
We're a little disappointed,
but.
Wow,
dude,
that's crazy,
man.
What a,
what a,
what an experience.
Yeah.
Those were,
those were fun days.
You know,
I think they're,
the puzzle's still around.
I'm not quite sure if it's still a black badge or not.
You know,
I've kind of,
I've drifted a little bit.
Defcon for me has become more of like a volunteering thing than a,
you know,
precipitation thing.
Right.
No,
that makes sense.
So we'll come back to some other career stuff,
but you mentioned the TLS scanning thing.
Talk to me a little bit about buffer over dot run,
both the DNS dot and TLS dot.
And tell me,
tell me a little bit about that project and how it ended up.
Yeah.
So the,
the DNS dot endpoint was just,
I would take the,
these are all just like,
honestly,
these are all just engineering efforts.
Okay.
Let me,
let me also just add a little bit.
So Sam ran a service,
DNS dot buffer dot buffer over dot run and TLS dot buffer over dot run.
These were tools that you could use for reconnaissance.
So you're saying DNS dot is an endpoint where.
Yeah.
So they were both free.
You know,
the,
the DNS endpoint,
it,
um,
sorry,
I just got to.
Something just dropped.
Who knows what that was?
I'm sorry.
So the,
so the DNS endpoint,
uh,
was one where,
um,
I would take the rapid seven public data and I would just index it and make a searchable because the rapid seven,
it was like this project sonar data at the time was publicly available,
but you would just get these like,
you know,
it was like seven gig downloads or something absurd.
And they'd be published like very often,
um,
like weekly.
And it was just like what saw the internet essentially.
And so I think that they had like hooks into a bunch of DNS infrastructure and then they'd just make it available.
Awesome.
Which was great.
And then they realized that they could charge for it and they started charging for it.
Did they yank it?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They yanked it.
No,
I don't think it's free anymore.
Oh my gosh.
I haven't looked into that in so long.
It's been years.
Yeah.
Like two or three years now.
It says that you can still get data.
I might have to register for it.
I think it requires registration at least.
Oh no,
it's actually,
yeah.
It's 47,
74 terabytes of data.
You can still get all the,
all the stuff.
It was last updated,
uh,
as early as today.
Oh,
interesting.
Okay.
Sorry.
Existing open data users can sign in for access.
It says,
yeah,
I think you're right,
Sam.
Yeah.
You got to sign up for,
and like request access.
But after that,
okay.
They,
they listed all at least.
It was no longer publicly available.
And if I recall at the time,
I felt it was a little bit sketchy,
like rehosting something that you have to get through.
Yeah.
That's probably,
yeah.
That means probably part of why they,
why they did it.
Yeah.
They're like,
Hey,
this guy's making it accessible.
It's tickling enough.
Someone is constantly pulling this down.
Yeah.
That's right.
Um,
but I mean,
to be fair,
no,
I was only doing like once a week.
Um,
you know,
I had a little like,
uh,
I don't know how to call it.
Cron job or whatever.
No,
it was the smallest VPS I could possibly buy.
I,
it was some,
one of those like European VPS hosters that was like,
you know,
like two euros a month.
Like,
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
There was,
I don't recall exactly which hosting provider it was,
but they were European.
And yeah,
for whatever reason,
it was just enough power to run this web server.
It was right.
Like 70% CPU,
like a percent of the time,
but it stayed up.
It stayed up.
Question mark.
Yeah.
And then,
and then after you,
so what you did with DNS scrap was you took that whole data set,
extracted it down a little bit,
sorted it.
So it'd be really easy to in,
you know,
jump through the indexes and then,
um,
and then you made it,
you know,
exposed an HTTP API for that.
Right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And you could download like good amount of data,
like a hundred megabytes or so at a time,
if you wanted to from that end point.
And I actually ended up putting,
uh,
at the time cloud flare in front of it,
just because like,
I would get like 90,
95% offload.
Cause everyone's searching for like yahoo.com.
Like,
yeah,
of course.
Everyone's searching for the same thing.
It was a recon pipelines.
So I was like,
all right,
but glad for in front of it.
And they offloaded like,
like just an absurd amount of data.
That's amazing.
Was there a lot of people who were like hitting you as well,
like hitting your APIs essentially,
and like done the same thing where they were like now taking all your data
and farming it into their own systems.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So we'll talk about that in a second with the TLS endpoint.
Cause that one was much worse,
honestly.
So with the TLS endpoint,
I,
um,
I implemented a system where I was like,
uh,
without,
I don't know how much detail I should get into here without like,
it'll explain why in a second,
I guess.
Um,
uh,
but I was scanning the public internet for TLS certs.
And I used to like,
you know,
uh,
I have a lot of TLS backgrounds.
So I used like every trick I could think of to make it as fast as
possible.
Um,
I wrote my own,
like modified and exist in TLS library to make it work.
Oh my gosh,
Sam,
what is wrong with you?
Normal things that everybody does.
Well,
that made it,
honestly though,
that made it affordable.
That made it so that I can afford to run this.
That's awesome.
You know?
Dude,
the amount of time you spent rewriting that TLS library costs you more than
that freaking compute power ever would.
Uh,
I don't know.
I was,
I was scanning the entire internet.
I was like,
I'm like,
there were a lot of like,
self-signed stuff or whatever.
Self-signed search that exists on the internet for like,
dev instances of things.
And, you know,
finding all those is extremely valuable.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
And like that led to a lot of bugs,
like a significant number of my finds for years,
honestly.
And so I then realized as I was like running this,
I eventually realized that folks were using this data and reselling it.
Like I essentially put up like a,
you know,
a rough terms of service and every request response download.
I was like,
please don't resell this.
Yeah.
It's all sold.
Like,
don't do legal things with this and don't resell it.
And I found a bunch of folks were selling it.
I think like three or four different companies and like,
Oh man.
How did,
how did you find that they were reselling it?
A couple of cases,
someone reached out to me.
And then a couple other cases,
like it was just like somebody posted like,
Oh,
like look at all this data,
and it listed their sources.
And it's like,
but for overrun was one of their sources.
You should have just put like,
Sam Erby is,
is amazing.example.com and all your data sets.
And then it started looking and seeing if any of them have it.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's a lot of less ethical things I could have done with that.
Like embedding fake IP addresses in there,
but I didn't,
it just didn't seem like the right thing to do.
Like even calling somebody out.
It's like a lot of these were like startups and stuff and they might not even
know.
Or like the other thing too,
is like in a lot of cases,
these are in other countries.
So there's no legal recourse.
Sure.
So long story short,
I was like,
okay,
I'm going to go like,
uh,
route three,
which is,
well,
I guess route four would shut this all down.
Route three was,
uh,
turns into your real product.
Yeah.
And so,
um,
I spent,
you know,
I,
I finally spent a little bit AWS budget.
I think I was spending like,
uh,
probably like a few hundred bucks a month on AWS and like,
turned this into like a whole real pipeline.
Like everything was much faster.
It was getting the internet way faster.
And then I used a rapid API to actually turn this into like a productionized API
endpoint.
And yeah,
it turns out like a bunch of companies that immediately signed up for it.
So like,
uh,
data,
data reselling companies,
immediately signed up for it at like an enterprise level.
So there were,
there was actually interest in this.
Um,
how much were you charging?
Uh,
the enterprise tier was only like 250 a month.
I,
yeah.
Underpriced that one a little bit,
didn't you,
A little bit.
Um,
but still like,
that's still like pretty good.
Right.
Like,
I think like,
again,
we're,
we're a little like jaded and abstracted,
but $250 a month per customer is like pretty soft.
It is good.
Not to,
not to diminish that at all,
but like,
but again,
like right on the scale of like enterprise applications,
I mean,
people charge 250,000 a month,
but it's just like,
you know,
like crazy.
Yeah.
So from there,
uh,
you know,
I brought a few customers,
I'm not going to be a good,
but I'm not going to be a good,
It's that they're very scanner friendly.
Um,
they're kind of a scanner friendly host.
they're,
yeah,
I've got a host like that too.
It's,
they're located in Sweden.
Yeah.
They're like a US,
I don't,
I don't fully understand how they operate.
Um,
to be blunt.
but,
you know,
port scanning isn't legal.
I don't,
I don't understand why everyone freaks out,
but like port scanning is legal.
Yeah.
I just,
yeah,
I don't,
maybe they just send their abuse emails to,
you know,
to,
yeah.
It's definitely,
whatever they do about it.
Um,
you know,
I was paying them like $500 a month for like a,
a bare metal server,
um,
to scan much faster.
So I was getting results on the entire internet in 24 hours and certain subsets of it in like an hour to 20 minutes.
That's great.
But then that's fast.
Yeah.
It was like almost instantaneous.
Like I would see.
Yeah.
Um,
and yeah,
I mean,
that to me was extremely valuable,
but then,
uh,
yeah,
the both getting this job,
but then also,
um,
the like support of all that infrastructure became a little bit much.
So I,
I reached out over to a friend who was at the time over at,
um,
recorded future.
Um,
and they ended up,
purchasing the whole thing.
Um,
you know,
it was,
it wasn't like amazing money,
but it's still good money.
So I was very happy to hand it off to them.
Very good.
Yeah.
It's cool to,
it's definitely on my bucket list to do like some little,
little project like that,
turn it into like the software as a service.
And then,
you know,
eventually exit it.
So that,
that's a,
I love to hear people doing that.
What,
what year was it when you exited?
Do you know?
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
It was around the time I tried Google.
Very cool.
Awesome.
Yeah.
That's really,
really interesting.
So final little section we had here was just talking about Google and,
uh,
your experience there and the whole,
um,
you know,
program that you guys have in place.
Um,
your current role at Google and involvement with the bug bounty side of it.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I,
my time at Google split between the bug bounty program and then,
um,
uh,
what we refer to as like kind of like product security reviews.
Um,
so,
you know,
looking at signs or things about the launch for their security,
um,
you know,
making sure it's good to go or answering any questions that the team might
have.
Uh,
but then the bug bounty side,
um,
I am part of the,
so,
I guess back it up,
but the way that our bug bounty,
uh,
program works is like our,
the,
at least on the Google bug bounty program.
Um,
we have a rotation of bug hunters or,
or,
um,
security engineer,
sorry,
who will accept reports from bug hunters and,
uh,
we'll,
we'll treat us in on like a weekly basis.
And then,
uh,
we,
we essentially take turns as striager for the week.
Um,
you know,
I think that this,
and so,
sorry,
to answer your question,
I'm,
I'm on that rotation,
but then I also helped out on the,
um,
you know,
on the help with the overall program,
help to try and make it better.
Um,
sure.
Yeah.
that,
that's gotta be interesting,
Being on the,
on the triage side,
especially for,
you know,
an attack surface as big as Google,
like that's gotta be nuts.
Before you started like working at Google,
or I guess maybe the same thing,
but before you were in the rotation,
before you started working there,
whatever,
had you hacked on Google at all?
Like,
but did you have any precursor knowledge about like what vulnerabilities
looked like,
what the infrastructure was like,
anything like that?
Um,
yes and no,
Uh,
like I had found,
um,
some bugs in Chrome actually.
Okay.
Yeah.
No big deal.
All right.
Off to the side,
like,
couple Chromium bugs,
you know.
Uh,
but I didn't actually,
I don't think I had,
I have to look through my email.
I don't think I actually had any on Google proper because like,
the minimization actually really slowed me down.
We actually just released a,
uh,
verb extension.
That will do pro decompiling for you.
Yeah,
I freaking love that.
Uh,
I'm,
we mentioned it on the pod a couple of weeks back when it first came out.
Um,
and I was like,
dang,
there goes my moat because,
uh,
of like,
you know,
built that exact same tool,
except it's not as good as yours.
Uh,
you know,
a couple of weeks back when we were hacking on Bard.
Um,
and so,
no,
I was glad to see that drop though.
Cause that really opens accessibility up a lot.
Um,
yeah,
that was,
that was really my,
what was holding me back anyways,
when I was looking at Google originally.
Um,
you know,
I think like honestly being on the,
being on the triage team,
like you really do see,
see just how many different services we have.
Um,
yeah,
we get,
we have bugs from.
Everywhere.
Yeah.
Uh,
sorry,
real quick,
Joel.
Um,
can you talk a little bit about that extension?
And like,
like,
were you writing it?
I know,
I know you're one of the cloud collaborators on the,
but like,
were you like the one hands on the keyboard writing it?
And could you talk a little bit about the,
the structure that Google uses in their request that makes it
kind of tricky?
Yeah.
Um,
so,
uh,
that extension was actually authored by a,
an integer we had over the summer.
Oh,
great.
That's awesome.
What a cool project.
Um,
yeah,
I think it worked out really well.
We actually ended up,
um,
it turns out that somebody,
uh,
or the,
the protobuf team actually had released a tool called,
uh,
protoscope,
um,
that kind of did exactly what we needed.
And so we kind of just glued the,
the,
the burp extension bits,
uh,
onto that.
Um,
and it actually ended up working out really well.
Nice.
Yeah,
that's cool.
But,
uh,
the reason that it's so complicated,
well,
is that you don't necessarily know the definition going over the wire.
Mm-hmm.
exactly.
So the,
when the JavaScript gets compiled,
it knows the definition,
but the adminify JavaScript,
you're not given the definition of the protobuf.
And that can make,
um,
request,
request and response manipulation very difficult,
uh,
in websites that use it.
Right.
Yeah.
And I,
like,
there were maybe two websites that I really were like,
my go-to's that were able to do essentially this,
like the produce,
like taking such just like a hex or a basic for blob of protobuf data.
And just saying like,
here's what the,
the type structure looks like.
Here's what the,
the field indexes are.
Good luck.
Um,
you know,
and it's awesome that this is now like an official tool.
And a CLI tool and now also a Burp extension so that you can sort of tie this into all your own tooling and all that,
all that other good fun stuff.
And,
uh,
sort of lower that,
that bar for,
for hacking on Google,
which is so super,
super awesome to see.
Yeah.
There's also a few others in there also,
like if there's something that the extension can't do,
you know,
there are,
there are a few other options listed.
Um,
and the,
uh,
we definitely looked at those,
um,
as we were,
as we're implementing this,
um,
you know,
for like,
just to both,
both just see how they worked,
but then also to,
um,
uh,
we wanted,
we wanted to provide that list just to give folks a choice.
Right.
So,
so with the extension that,
that Lupin built,
uh,
in that we were using,
on Bard,
um,
essentially it would kind of do some deobfuscation and like,
you know,
adding and that sort of thing.
But at the end of the day,
you're still not getting like parameter names and stuff like that.
You're still,
you're just getting like,
okay,
here's an array.
You know,
we know that this is like,
you know,
a string,
like,
completely like decorative,
like structurally wise.
Like all it cares about is what,
what is the index,
like the field ID number and what type is it?
And beyond that,
like you could name it whatever you want.
It's really just like,
you know,
extra.
So,
so for those of you with,
cause I hacked on Bard for like a week,
so I've got a very rudimentary understanding of it,
but the,
the,
um,
part of the reversing process then becomes,
okay.
What is this?
Yeah.
What the heck is this thing?
Right?
I just now added field 19.
What is field 19?
Where does this come from?
Yeah.
Exactly.
So,
you're really,
you're spending a,
you're much more blind.
You're,
you're trying to sort of create,
um,
deductions about how the requests is actually being formatted and what,
you know,
numeric ID is being used where,
what string is being used where,
um,
any,
any tips or thoughts for that,
or is it really,
you just gotta,
you know,
get through to,
um,
a little bit more difficult hacking where you're just sitting there and just
trying to make sense of even what you're seeing,
let alone trying to figure out how the backend works.
Um,
I mean,
the,
if you see,
you know,
the one tip I'll give actually is like,
if you see missing fields,
try and putting something in there.
Yeah.
Um,
So it's like stuff that's out of order.
Well,
you'll get stuff out of order,
but you also get field numbering when you,
um,
when you decompile and recompile it.
And so like,
I don't know if you have like fields,
like one,
two and five,
like what are three or four?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's interesting.
Cause,
cause you know,
uh,
also one of the problems I ran into was that it,
it doesn't give verbose errors ever.
Right.
So it's like error five.
And I'm like,
no,
like not error five again.
You know?
And so it's good to hear that,
like actually just,
you know,
trying to insert stuff at different indexes may actually do something.
Um,
because,
you know,
it could in my,
in my head,
you know,
I was thinking,
uh,
they probably have something very specific they're looking for.
And if I just,
if I do anything besides like change the ID numbers or,
you know,
anything like that,
it's going to hack everything up.
You know,
it depends on the application.
Sorry.
Dang it.
Yeah.
I was,
I wanted the,
I wanted the silver bullet,
Sam.
Like,
yeah.
Become a Google employee and read the PDFs.
Yeah.
I don't have to deal with this shit.
I got the proto files,
you know,
like I got the,
I got the definitions on this side.
We have hired bug hunter before,
I think,
Ezequiel who's,
who's won a bunch of the cloud awards.
We hired him.
Very cool.
Yeah.
We'll have to chat about that after.
So I guess,
so,
you know,
you're on the triage team.
You see a lot of,
a lot of bugs coming through there.
Um,
any crazy stories,
any crazy stories you want to share,
or are we diving too deep into the,
the unknown or the things that we're not allowed to probe about?
So this is like,
this is the interesting part is that I can't talk about these bugs,
but as bug reporters,
we don't hold folks to NDAs.
So you're welcome to talk about your bugs.
Like active bugs.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy,
man.
That's,
I've heard that before.
If you say you're going to disclose,
we'll send you a standardized disclosure notice.
I'm not going to paraphrase it,
but,
um,
yeah,
we're not going to hold you to NDAs.
Wow.
That's really cool.
Yeah.
That's one of the few programs out there that really like,
actually lets you do that pretty freely because almost every other big program is like,
all right,
if you want to get paid for it,
then mom's the word,
you know?
yeah.
I mean,
if you read blog posts about it too,
like,
we'll like retweet it and stuff.
And,
wow.
That's clutch.
They're even going to promote it.
Yeah.
you know,
we want,
we want more folks finding bugs and yeah.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I will say actually one of the,
one of the more interesting reports that came through,
um,
and so sorry,
backing up,
I guess.
Um,
so the,
I don't know if you've paid attention recently,
but like,
uh,
over the past year,
I guess we've,
we've lost,
we've lost a lot of,
uh,
different,
um,
uh,
kind of,
different bug bounty programs is the best way to describe them.
I wanted to ask about that.
Cause there's like,
you know,
the,
the one where it's like,
you get a bunch of,
uh,
you know,
any app above a hundred million,
installs that's in scope for Google,
the Google plays,
you know,
thing,
and there's the VRP and then there's some AI stuff.
So like,
there's a bunch going on.
Well,
so one in particular that I want to call out is,
um,
the abuse therapy.
And this is something that like,
I didn't,
before joining,
I didn't have a lot of insight into.
Um,
so like when we are,
um,
when we are like rewarding payments through the Google VRP,
we'll actually at the same time do the abuse therapy,
because often there are,
there are bugs where it's applicable to both.
And we'll just like reward everyone's highest.
What is the abuse of VRP?
I was going to say like what falls under.
Yeah.
So it's used the example.
Um,
recently somebody reported that,
uh,
they received like a really convincing phishing email that,
um,
and this is like this,
they actually read about this publicly.
So I'm talking about it.
Um,
it became a problem with the BIMI protocol.
it had some sort of like email.
I,
this is pushing the limits of what I,
uh,
know about this,
um,
it's some sort of,
uh,
email user identification system.
Oh,
I'm reading.
This brand brand indicators for message identification.
It's,
it's kind of like SPF for DKIM or,
um,
DMARC or one of those,
like,
I guess it's just an additional sort of security layer.
Brand indicators for what?
They're additional DNS,
uh,
BIMI,
brand,
uh,
indicators for message identification.
Wow.
So somebody reported a problem that they like received like a really convincing phishing email through this.
Um,
and like,
that's not,
you know,
phishing emails don't like quite fit cleanly under the rules of our VRP necessarily.
Mm.
And,
but under the abuse of RP,
like this is like a very clear cut,
like this can be used to abuse our products.
And so,
um,
like we accepted through that,
but then like,
you know,
I think that actually results in like RFC updates.
Like they,
they weren't,
they weren't aware that this could be an attack.
I don't recall the exact details,
but it did,
it did get some of these back.
Uh,
a few months ago.
So it sounds like kind of the distinction is like more like re repurposing intended functionality,
or at least like featured functionality for like a bad purpose versus something that's like a security vulnerability.
And maybe they kind of like overlap a little bit,
but like one is more like classical than the other.
Is that,
is that kind of the gist?
Yeah.
I think that's the right way to look at it.
Like,
like there's,
there's things that are cleanly technical security vulnerabilities.
Like RFC would be a clean security vulnerability or like,
uh,
clean abuse.
Like you can,
I don't know,
like steal money from somebody.
Yeah.
Let me,
let me,
let me read this really quickly.
And significant abuse related methodologies are also in scope for this program.
If the reported attack scenario displays a designer implementation issue in Google products that could lead to significant harm.
An example of an abuse related methodology would be a technique by which an attacker is able to manipulate the rating score of a listing on Google Maps by submitting a sufficiently large volume of fake reviews that go undetected by our abuse system.
That's really cool.
Super cool.
Yeah.
And so we get,
we get a lot of reports where like,
you know,
we forwarded to that team.
Yeah.
I imagine so.
So I wanted to ask like,
because Google is so huge and you guys probably receive a lot of reports.
Um,
how do you go sort of about like,
drawing the line for like,
this is stuff we don't care about because I can imagine that there,
you can,
you know,
rework all your bugs in one way or another and make it so that like,
technically it falls under some form of either abuse or technical security issue.
And how do you stop like that from overloading the internal teams with like lots of little nitpicky things that don't really like that,
that maybe they should fix,
but not doesn't need to happen tomorrow.
Like,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
we have a lot of automation on our side that helps us that,
especially with that first level of like,
look at the report.
Like,
do we even own this URL?
Um,
yeah,
actually I got a,
I got,
when I submitted a bug,
it's like,
I got an email back saying,
uh,
by Google magic,
we know,
this is like within like two minutes of me submitting the bug.
It's like,
Google magic.
We know that this is a valid report or like something like that.
Oh,
That's kind of crazy.
Like,
we do have a,
I need some of that magic.
Yeah.
Seriously.
Uh,
so I should preface this by saying,
well,
I should preface by saying that security engineers will still look at every report.
Um,
that really impacts the order,
which was true at things.
Uh,
but we do have like a first pass,
like machine learning,
uh,
system that will look at every report and knows what's previously been valid and invalid.
Um,
I should also say just before I go any further that like,
anything I say here at the rules pages,
take precedent.
Um,
in case I make mistakes.
Yeah,
that's,
that's fair.
That's fair.
You know,
if you go under the bug hunters website,
Sam,
you said on the CTPP podcast that I could submit phishing emails.
Uh,
uh,
but then,
so then if you go to the bug hunters website,
if you go under,
um,
the invalid report section,
there are a few,
a few different categories there,
um,
often will catch folks off guard.
Um,
the one big one,
especially is,
um,
open redirects.
Like there's a few places where we have intentional open redirects that,
uh,
do have security properties.
Slash amp.
Yeah.
Um,
those are,
those are intentional.
Um,
and we often get reports around those.
I,
uh,
I saw a tweet a while back.
There was like,
Hey,
I can only,
uh,
you're in luck because slash amp,
you hit slash amp with that open redirect and it'll,
uh,
redirect you to whatever domain you want.
Um,
and you know,
that's,
that's just a gadget that's been in place for a while.
And this is just a comment on a,
you know,
on a Twitter response.
And everyone was like,
like retweet,
like,
you know,
like I spend so much time like writing,
like very thoroughly thought through.
Yeah.
Very,
very thorough responses.
And then this one just like blows up because Google's got an open redirect.
They won't fix.
come on.
I would,
when they won't fix,
I would look on the about page to understand more of our logic.
No.
let me be clear.
I don't think it's a problem.
I don't think it's a problem because Google,
you know,
I,
let me,
let me challenge that a little bit.
I think it is.
I don't have all the context in your organization.
I think it's a little bit irresponsible to,
to do something like that.
Um,
because I use open redirects and chains like every day,
you know?
Um,
and so ideally that would be fixed,
but the thing is Google is a,
is a,
you know,
a search engine and the,
the part of the business case is redirecting users,
you know,
to things.
So,
um,
I'm sure there's a perfectly valid,
you know,
use case word on your side,
but I will say I've used that redirecting chains many times.
I will say also the,
that there are,
and then once again,
look at the invalid reports,
redirect page for a lot more technical information around this.
I probably should have read it before I joined this.
Um,
uh,
I have it open.
I'll,
we'll put a link down below.
Yeah.
We'll drop it.
There are a lot of cases where we do accept those.
Oh really?
Interesting.
There is like,
you know,
JavaScript redirects,
obviously.
ones that aren't intentional might get rewarded.
Interesting.
And I'd look at that page once again.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
Well,
we'll add it.
Um,
yeah.
JavaScript redirects,
client side redirects.
there,
there is a lot of use cases with that,
especially with the,
with the onset of,
um,
same site cookies and just whether or not things are going to be sent cookies,
depending on where the request originated from.
And when you do a client side redirect via JavaScript,
you,
um,
you really,
you're sending different cookies along if you had just done it from a third party,
top level nav.
So,
I know, sorry.
I mean like a little more like,
uh,
open redirect to cross-site scripting,
but yeah.
Oh, okay.
Open redirect to cross-site scripting.
Okay.
Well,
it's interesting,
you know,
JavaScript level redirects.
I think that I'd be surprised if you guys accepted those,
but I,
I also wouldn't be surprised in that there,
I think.
Yeah.
I actually, sorry.
I don't know if we accept those.
I really,
I really didn't know the,
the,
Oh,
the redirect to.
Yeah, sure.
And where you can snag it by cross-site scripting.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Um,
that's cool, man.
Yeah.
There's a lot of different,
there's a lot of,
I'm on the,
the page for,
I guess,
bug hunters.google.com.
And there's a ton of different,
uh,
programs here on the left-hand side,
Android and Google device security reward program,
all the way to alphabet program,
to open source,
to OS fuzz or OSS fuzz.
So like,
there's a ton of stuff here.
Um,
so that's a big job you got going on there,
Sam.
We have a large team and like,
we want to,
we want to reward good vulnerabilities.
you know,
I think that if you want to see some other cool ones,
some of my favorites have been on the,
um,
the,
there's yearly,
there in the past years have been cloud,
uh,
cloud rewards for like the best GCP.
Ah,
GCP stuff.
Um,
you know,
those are always like super creative.
Um,
um,
there've been some great read ups there as well.
Very nice.
Um,
you added something to the doc here,
hacking Google.
And it's like,
uh,
like it's,
it's one of the coolest things I've ever seen,
to be honest.
Like I,
I,
uh,
this was not on my radar at all.
And we're going to link this down below,
but it,
apparently it's like a,
a multi series,
uh,
almost like a documentary of like,
essentially hacks that have happened with Google,
you know,
and,
hacking related stuff at Google.
Um,
super well produced.
Yeah.
They went all out with this.
Talk to me about that.
I mean,
it's only a year old and there's like millions and millions and millions of views on it.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
this,
I probably can best describe this as like,
this is like,
this is what I show my grandparents to,
to them that I do.
Um,
like,
that's awesome.
It tries to put it to like,
you know,
into something that's publicly consumable,
like,
you know,
by everybody,
what we do as security engineers.
Um,
it talks about a bunch of different teams.
the one that I linked to there is,
uh,
the one on our,
bug bounty team.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Is that the,
let me see episode four.
Yeah.
Cause I only,
I only got through some of them.
Yeah.
Episode,
episode four.
That was the one I clicked.
I,
yeah,
it's really well done.
I really like that series.
Yeah.
The first one,
Operation Aurora.
I,
I watched that one.
I got to go record the podcast.
Okay.
So no,
I'm going to go back and check that out.
Also,
they've got a project zero section as well,
which is such a cool,
um,
part of Google.
Um,
definitely check out the,
uh,
hacking Google series.
Um,
I think that we're already at an hour 30.
That kind of concludes what I had on the,
uh,
on the list here.
Um,
did you have anything else you wanted to shout out or talk about,
uh,
before we,
no,
thank you for having me.
Thank y'all for having me on here.
You know,
this was a great experience.
Of course, man.
Yeah.
You can find Sam on,
on Twitter,
Irby Sam.
And I don't know,
do you even use your LinkedIn?
I've got it here,
but,
uh,
or X,
Irby Sam with two V's.
Um,
thanks for coming on and sharing your knowledge,
man.
And,
uh,
looking forward to our next,
and,
uh,
awesome.
Peace.
All right.
I,
I ended the podcast before Sam talked to us about cool bugs.
So I mentioned,
um,
on the SAML podcast a while back that,
uh,
Sam was one of the first people that introduced me to XSLT.
Um,
and so Sam,
I was wondering if you could share a little bit about that bug and yeah,
just kind of talk to us about that.
Yeah.
So this was at,
this is like one of the first life hack events I attended.
Uh,
and,
uh,
there was this end point that accepted,
um,
it was XML,
but it wasn't XML.
It's XSLT,
which is like a data transformation language.
Okay.
So it accepted,
uh,
XSLT directly.
Yes.
Um,
but it,
it would accept like,
it was like,
you would accept like your,
your input and then the XSLT to transform it with.
Um,
and so it's one of those like,
uh,
business logic type languages that like,
well,
I'm probably butchering this for XSLT experts.
Um,
but it's one of those business logic type languages that allow you to transform data and kind of arbitrarily and like a user friendly way.
Like,
you know,
somebody who can write an Excel document can go and write this XML format.
Um,
and so apparently after,
as I found out,
like actually a lot of folks,
sort of folks at the slide packing event found this endpoint and just kind of did a simple,
like,
XSCT payload and kind of called it a day.
Um,
yep.
I decided to spend a bunch of extra hours digging into this.
Classic,
classic Sam.
So what I actually ended up doing was like,
I actually went to the function reference and I stepped through every function.
Uh,
I'm sorry,
hold up.
What?
Yeah.
So,
so you,
you,
you know,
leaked the library name and then set up your own local instance and then hook up a debugger.
I mean,
well,